poltergeists the 2015 edition star Sam
Rockwell and rosemary DeWitt and it's
the remake of the original poltergeist
that was directed by tobe Hooper between
you and me Steven Spielberg probably
directed this movie and the story hasn't
really changed at all family moves into
a new house weird stuff is going on
there's noises there sounds in the
closet the girl touches the TV and says
they're here we've seen it before and
we're seeing it again because everything
is going to be remade that we ever liked
ever when it comes to the new
poltergeist I couldn't help but think
the same thing throughout the entire
movie it's just really necessary
do we really need to see poltergeist
again this movie barely takes any
chances and doesn't really do anything
unique or different with what we've
already seen before this movie has an
extreme over-reliance on CGI there is
way way too much of it and it's really
not that good when you have a movie
that's so relying on these humongous
green-screen environments in which kids
have to walk through like this hallway
just filled with all these moving
computer-generated things it just
doesn't look real and since it doesn't
look real it's not scary that's one of
the things that made the conjuring the
babadook and insidious very frightening
to me there was hardly any CGI in those
films very very little hand it was
terrifying when you saw some head
this creep and I had a closet and it was
horrible it was like oh crap
that's scary this movie doesn't have any
of that it's just a bunch of CGI stuff
that's like crawling out of the walls
and it just looks fake I'm sorry it
looks fake and some of the things this
movie decided to do differently you just
shrug your head as to why it's there
like a CGI squirrel jumping out of a
closet and then it's a CGI squirrel
running around the room and you're like
why is there a CGI squirrel no I don't
want to get too negative here because
this is at times a competently made film
by far the best part of this movie is
Sam Rockwell but he's pretty much the
best part of any movie that he's in this
guy's great he is a fantastic actor
rosemary DeWitt is also excellent Jared
Hess is good there is some good acting
this movie some of the kids are a little
iffy I'll be honest about that
now in my opinion the only reason to
make a remake of a movie
is maybe the idea was really cool and
the movie just wasn't that good like
Judge Dredd with Sylvester Stallone they
made Dredd with Karl Urban and it was
just like freakin great let's just say
as a filmmaker a writer or director you
are forced to make a remake you have to
do this because it's your job and you're
contractually obligated whatever you
have to make the poltergeist remake what
can you do to improve upon it well you
could take some horror cliches of
previous decades and eliminate them and
improve upon them one of the biggest
ones that needs to go away is the young
child who for some reason is not afraid
of demons and ghosts yeah you're four or
five years old you're a little girl and
your closet is freakin talking to you at
night and you're just like hey little
demons in the closet hi hey guys the
demons are here hey hey guys
No okay oh you're four years old and
there's like skeleton demon creature
monsters in your closet talking to you
you're done okay you pee your pants you
run to your parents you're done I'm so
tired of the horror movie kid who's like
yay ghosts are cool they're not they're
not cool they're not no again another
reason I love the babadook the kid in
this movie gets scared he's freaked out
when his mom starts acting crazy and
he's afraid of this babadook thing he's
freaking terrified that's how it should
be so they had an opportunity to take
some of those cliches of the previous
decades and remove them but they did
them again also the movie ends
incredibly abruptly okay one of my
favorite sequences that's in the
original poltergeist I'm not going to
spoil anything for anyone it was the one
sequence I was kind of interested to see
how the remake handled it and they
didn't even include it it just it just
ends there's no more movie it is the
most abrupt like 2015 let's play a pop
song ending I'm serious it was such an
abrupt ending I actually ripped my 3d
glasses off and stared at the screen it
was like it's over
Wow guys I'm going to be totally real
with you here I can see that if you went
and saw this movie having never seen the
original poltergeist you might think
those are some really clever and
inventive sequences that's
impressive there are some well directed
sequences in this movie and like I said
directly performances - and there are
some effective scares a couple of them
but they're all basically from a movie
that already exists and is directed
better so really what is the purpose of
this movie existing except to make money
guys I'm going to give poltergeist a
c-minus my honest recommendation to you
if you've never seen the original
poltergeist and you thought this newer
film looked cool and you were going to
go see it do yourself a favor check out
the original and I can give you the best
reason why Stephen frickin Spielberg
thank you so much as always for watching
guys I do really appreciate it and if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes